Acting is a profession that requires a lot
of versatility and willingness to test boundaries.
In the act of immersion, sometimes the script
calls for things that the actor himself would
never even consider, yet they have to play
it naturally.
And sometimes that results in a complete nightmare
for everyone involved.
Here are some movie scenes that actors regret
doing.
A Titanic drawing
Maybe the most memorable scene in Titanic
is the one where Kate Winslet's Rose character
asks Leonardo DiCaprio's Jack to "draw me
like one of your French girls."
It's a passionate moment showing her character
overcoming the disapproval of her fiancé
and mother to claim her own agency and embrace
the man she's fallen in love with.
"As a paying customer, I expect to get what
I want."
But now obsessive fans try to get Winslet
to sign pictures of herself naked.
And she'd love for that to stop.
She told Yahoo!
News, "I don't sign that picture.
It feels very uncomfortable.
Why would you do that?"
Why indeed.
Give that man a shirt
Taylor Lautner played the werewolf character
Jacob in the Twilight series, and his transformations
usually left him shirtless, if not completely
naked.
Fans loved it, but Lautner worries now that
his pecs might overshadow his acting.
He told Ace Showbiz, "If I had to choose,
I would never take my shirt off again in a
movie, but I guess that's not very realistic.
I certainly won't be asking to do it, though."
A change of heart
In the 2013 action comedy Kick-Ass 2, Jim
Carrey plays a superhero called Colonel Stars
and Stripes who's gruesomely murdered by supervillains.
A few months after the film was released,
Carrey publicly condemned the level of violence
in the film after experiencing change of heart
in the aftermath of the tragic Sandy Hook
Massacre, which happened shortly after he'd
wrapped up filming his scenes.
"I did Kick-Ass 2 a month before Sandy Hook
and now in all good conscience I cannot support
that level of violence....
I am not ashamed of it but recent events have
caused a change in my heart."
While that's a respectable stand to take,
the bosses at Universal Pictures probably
wished Carey had figured that out before taking
the role.
Icky drunk stuff
Passengers is a science fiction adventure
starring Jennifer Lawrence and Chris Pratt.
Despite the star-power of its cast, it didn't
do very well at the box office, partly due
to backlash against a crucial plot point that
involves a startling disregard for the consent
and personal autonomy of one of the characters.
Which wasn't helped by Jennifer Lawrence admitting
that she spent the love scenes too drunk to
remember doing them.
She told CNN she had jitters about the shoot
because it was going to be her first time
filming a love scene and also felt guilty about
doing so with Pratt, who's married.
"I got really drunk.
But that led to more anxiety because I was
like 'What have I done?
I don't know'…
And it was gonna be my first time kissing
a married man, and the guilt is the worst
feeling in your stomach."
That leg cross
In Basic Instinct, Sharon Stone plays writer-slash-murderer
Catherine Tramell, who uses her wits and
appeal to easily manipulate the men around
her, especially in the iconic scene where,
by simply uncrossing her legs and *ahem* "flashing
the cash" during a police interrogation, she
completely reverses the balance of power.
"It's nice."
Which is sort of ironic, because according
to Stone, the scene itself turns out to be
born of manipulation and a violation of consent.
Stone claims she was asked by director Paul
Verhoeven to remove her underwear because
the flashes of white were messing up the shot.
She was assured there would be no nudity visible
on camera and didn't discover she had been
tricked until she saw the finished film — in
a room full of other people.
She responded by slapping Verhoeven, who has
publicly denied Stone's claims, saying, "it's
a lie."
There's a wall there
In The Phantom Menace, Terence Stamp plays
Chancellor Valorum, who's ushered out in favor
of the secret Sith Lord Palpatine thanks to
a vote of "no confidence" from Queen Amidala,
played by Natalie Portman.
It's about as exciting to watch as an actual
Senate hearing, but it's important to the
overall plot, or what passes for one.
Stamp signed on to the movie for the sole
purpose of getting to act with Natalie Portman.
However, when he actually arrived on set,
Portman was nowhere in sight, and Stamp was
directed to aim his dialogue towards a piece
of paper on the wall instead.
He told IndieWire, "It was just pretty boring."
Which, not coincidentally, also sums up the
entire movie.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!